je lui fais dire un de ses potes hein il
cause avec il lui dit quand on mettra
les cons sur orbite tu as pas fini de
tourner il y a pas un mot d'Argo là
dedans vous pouvez démonter la froide et
on dit c'est de l'argot c'est pas vrai
il y a pas un seul mon argent
pourquoi la mise en scène pourquoi
devenir metteur en scène
oh c'est un petit peu pour changer mais
surtout pour me reposer un peu parce que
j'ai fait 72 films comme dialogistes et
écrire c'est quand même fatiguant quoi
qu'on pense dans un peu plus simple on
dit on dit moteur on dit couper on dit
des petites choses comme ça c'est pas
une dépense énorme diriger les acteurs
c'est aussi une chose avec elle je crois
pas tellement parce que si on en prend
des bons il se dirige tout seul si on en
a des mauvais il y a pas des régions
c'est cette même assez simple
apparemment je fais un film j'ai
Françoise Roset on dirait je crois
François Rozel elle a été des années
l'épouse de Jacques FEDER qui est un des
plus grands metteur en scène du monde je
vais pas lui apprendre grand chose sur
le plan je lui donne des places et puis
un texte à dire puis toutes les grimaces
que je pourrais faire c'est on va à
grand chose en dehors de ça il y a un
petit côté
de puissance parce que le metteur en
scène c'est un peu de Dieu le Père quoi
il crée des personnages il dit que la
lumière soit et la lumière est c'est pas
un peu grise quand même non oh Instagram
en fait il y a aussi toutes les il y a
beaucoup de responsabilités que j'avais
pas avant quand même parce que par
exemple pour obtenir certaines choses du
producteur autrefois je disais au
metteur en scène comment on appelle ça
des meilleurs gueuler et on l'aura
maintenant je m'appelle ça avec de
gueuler c'est pas tellement c'est pas
c'est pas que ce soit difficile mais
c'est assez inefficace oui finalement on
a que ce qu'on veut bien vous donner
pour faire un film d'ailleurs je fais un
film un petit budget je me lance pas
dans une opération mais pas dans
grandiose alors Michel vous cultivez
votre jardin
parce que moi personnellement la
botanique si je reconnais les tulipes ah
bon ça va pas plus loin il est rose
quand elles sont bien sorties c'est ça
pas un bouton bien sûr c'est trop
difficile quand même vous voir là un
petit peu rurale parce que vous êtes un
homme du 14e
14e arrondissement ah oui je l'ai pas
quitté avant j'avais 30 ans je passais
même pas si on le droit d'aller à
l'époque
il y a une espèce d'ailleurs de
conditions d'hommes du 14e il y a une
convention navigateurs
c'est le quartier le plus intéressant de
Paris il y a pas de touristes il y a
rien d'ailleurs je parle du Canadiens
qui a 14e on a les monuments les plus
laides de Paris le Lion de Belfort
l'église de Montrouge mais c'est voulu
ça c'est pour décourager les les
autocars on franchit pas les limites de
14e la rue de la gaieté grand maximum
quand on écrit des dialogues sur le
cinéma comme vous
on peut pas couper le cordon ombilical
avec Paris
assez régulièrement parce qu'il est
évident que si on vit à la campagne
c'est vite terminé ce métier là parce
que il y a les il y a les mots nouveaux
surtout si on use un peu de l'argot ce
qu'on me rapproche d'ailleurs volontiers
mais c'est la seule langue qui bouge
tout de même sans ça on parlera encore
comme on dit 18e siècle il y a que
l'argot qui fonctionne un peu alors
Largo on n'entend pas beaucoup en bourse
quand même faut pas rêver oui parce que
il y a un problème du langage qui est
très important enfin il a pris il a pris
même une importance considérable dans
les mœurs aujourd'hui puisque certains
font dépendre d'évolution du monde du
langage et pour vous la langage se
renouvelle de quelle façon il se
renouvelle que Bernardo parce que
l'autre soir j'ai vu à la télé bah ils
ont une émission avec Monsieur Lévis
trop ce que certainement un esprit
distingué je n'en doute pas à l'instant
moi je comprends pas une blague de ce
qu'il annonce
rien j'ai pas compris
c'est un petit peu mon métier là il
parle une langue que j'ignore je
comprends rien c'est pour ça que je me
réfugie dans des romanciers moi comme si
non parce qu'il parle avec les 1300 mots
que je connais c'est tout le monde peut
reposant Instagram un choix alors
puisque nous sommes revenus au cinéma
que vous êtes metteur en scène quelle
est d'après vous l'archétype vous voyez
comme je parle à mon tour du metteur en
scène que moi je présente pour vous le
mettant en scène bah il y a un avis
une définition il m'a dit de mettre en
scène c'est un monsieur qui a une grosse
montre pour surveiller ses acteurs se
devinent pas dans cette mais je crois
que c'est un petit peu ça c'est drôle
que le cinéma parfois jouissent d'une
mauvaise réputation dit par exemple ne
me fait pas de cinéma tu me fais du
cinéma
les blousons à carreaux on a un viseur
on gueule on a un haut-parleur c'est ça
qu'on appelle faire du cinéma mais je
crois qu'on peut faire de la mise en
scène sans blouson à carreau et sans
parler on peut porter une casquette mais
ça je l'ai toujours pas
Michel le film avec lequel vous faites
vos débuts de mettant en scène nous en
avait fait également le scénario et des
dialogues vous rejoignez donc le cinéma
d'auteur oui j'ai fait confiance à
personne comment il s'appelle faut pas
prendre les enfants du bon Dieu pour des
canards sauvages c'est un petit peu long
mais enfin moi je crois que j'ai une
expression courante tout le monde
connaît enfin un bon français ça veut
dire faut pas prendre les minions pour
des caves
bien sûr quelle est la part de
l'érotisme dans votre œuvre est assez
limité jusqu'ici dans un film une fois
on a mis l'innoventura en caleçon mais
enfin c'est pas c'est pas l'érotisme
suédois
et dans celui-là vous allez franchir à
nouveau stade il y a un petit peu il y a
un peu d'érotiques je voudrais faire une
tentative d'érotisme comique je trouve
c'est ce qui manque au cinéma érotique
qui est actuellement prodigieusement
ennuyeux alors je vais je vais essayer
de donner une petite note d'humour à
l'érotisme et je crois avoir trouvé
d'ailleurs l'actrice pour rêver pour ce
genre de numéro de trapèze c'est Marlène
Jobert je la connaissais pas il y a deux
semaines et j'ai vu le film d'Yves
Robert Alexandre de bienheureux et en
sortant j'étais emballé par cette fille
j'ai demandé à Daniel Delorme quelle est
cette fille qui joue dans le film de ton
mari elle est formée elle est même pas
retenu son nom sur le générique et elle
me dit c'est la petite Jobert elle était
pas temps de va la voir au théâtre dans
Black comédie je suis allé au théâtre
conviction était faite je vais avoir un
après je vais déverrouiller vous faire
mon film elle m'a tout de suite répondu
oui ce que j'ai en plus je trouvais très
sympathique alors je pense que pour être
tout à fait dans le vent vous avez fait
aussi la part la violence il y a un
petit peu de violence mais c'est une
histoire de gangster au fond mais de
gangsters complètement bruns c'est c'est
déjà urique Camille toujours agréable de
se référer à ses propres œuvres en
disant qu'il y a un petit cousinage avec
les tontons flingueurs à ceci prête dans
les tontons flingueurs ils étaient tous
des braves types ils étaient gentils là
ils sont mauvais comme des teignes
c'est Françoise Roset ah oui François
rôle de François Joseph ah oui ça c'est
une vieille assassine là dedans elle en
repasse une vingtaine
la terre
[Musique]
n'aie pas peur non merci
c'est bien que c'est jamais fait de mal
[Musique]
une trentaine je me par un chiffre
raisonnable
[Musique]
satisfaisaient une sorte de sadisme
inconscient et votre cas non pas chez
moi
dans une langue un petit peu verte mais
par gothique je suis jamais d'accord
avec avec les gens parce que maintenant
on vous dit c'est de l'argot tout est de
l'argot c'est pas vrai il y a pas
d'argot il y a une langue de la rue une
langue parlée par exemple dans le
dernier film que j'ai fait Gabin c'est
un exemple entre 1000 je lui fais dire
un de ses potes il cause avec il lui dit
quand on mettra les cons sur orbite tu
n'as pas fini de tourner il y a pas un
mot d'Argo là dedans vous pouvez
démonter la froide et on dit c'est de
l'argot pas vrai il y a pas un seul mon
argent c'est plutôt de la
science-fiction
vous avez créé un jour je ne crois pas à
l'inspiration c'est vrai oui ça j'y
crois pas du tout parce que c'est un
métier le cinéma vous voyez
une feuille de papier faut la remplir
moi si je mets pas une feuille de papier
devant mon nez comme je déteste
travailler je travaillerai jamais j'ai
pas je me promène pas dans mon jardin en
disant tout d'un coup
ça y est d'ailleurs j'ai moi j'ai pas de
message je ferai pas des films sur la
guerre ou sur de ça ça m'insupporte
alors actuellement le Vietnam c'est
insupportable vous pouvez pas vous faire
chier quelqu'un sans déboucher sur la
plaine des gens toutes les conversations
moi j'ai rien à dire sur le Vietnam ça
ne comme on dit ça ne me concerne pas
alors premier tour de manivelle lundi
accompagné de quelques caprices vous
promettait d'en faire quelques le
premier jour pour impressionner l'équipe
après je me cache un petit
[Musique]